how important is it to stay dry is it
basically impossible it's impossible to
stay dry you're wet all the time you're
wet all the time what does that mean
that means infections are more efficient
yeah
um so yeah I don't know if you saw the
picture in my book where I have the
yellow spots yeah so yeah there's a
picture
with your like entire face consumed with
yellow spots is basically I guess that's
MRSA yep
oh boy uh so how did that happen what uh
what was the infection like and
um yeah and how crazy are you for
letting that affection stay in you for a
prolonged period of time without
treating it or you had no choice no I I
did have a choice I was 19 years old and
I was taking care of a giant anteater
there was orphaned and this is like my
dream animal yeah and she was mine and
my job was to teach her the jungle and
so when I started like noticing that I
had an infection and that I was I had I
think I had Dengue at the time too I
went back to town
probably picked up MRSA in the hospital
where I got tested
came back into the jungle and then got
progressively sicker and sicker and way
weaker and weaker as I was two weeks
three weeks in the jungle and then it
got to the point where my vision went
black and white and I passed out one day
and and I don't know why but at the time
I had shaved that day
and when I woke up the next morning I
couldn't open my eyes because the the
pus had come out of my eyes yeah and out
of my the pores in my face all those
little micro cuts and the pillow was
stuck to my face and
I was stuck up River with no help at 19
years old and also when you when you see
that picture you can imagine that I
assumed
that my life was over because I didn't
know what it was and I also didn't
assume that or at the very least I
figured I'd be disfigured the rest of my
life I didn't think there was any
getting better from that
and so I remember sitting by the side of
the river praying that a boat would come
by but it was the rainy season there
aren't going to be any boats because the
river's psychotic
um and so
it was a long time before I got back to
town and I didn't want to leave the
anteater but it became like I was like I
realized I was dying
and then I I finally got a boat with
some loggers a death boat just loaded
with these guys were had had gone into
the jungle and shot everything they
could and taken all the babies and they
were gonna go sell them and so it was
like baby monkeys and toucans and birds
in cages and pieces of crocodiles and
Anaconda skins and jaguar skins rolled
up and it was just like I was just
laying there with all these dead animals
in the boat with all the Flies on my
face and
got back to the hotel called my mother
said please book me a flight out like
today like today and then I sat on the
plane and somebody somebody sat next to
me on the plane and I had a hood on and
I do I do remember that in my in the
haze at this point I was having trouble
staying conscious but I do remember that
she like looked over like trying to see
what was sitting next to her and then
she got up and never came back
and when I got to to immigration in New
York you know the cop where he like
takes my passport and he goes yeah he
goes so what were you doing in Peru he's
looking down and he goes yeah and he
like holds up the passport looks at the
past what looks at my face he goes Bo
buddy what the [__] and I said no that's
why I was like I'm trying to get home to
go to the hospital he goes He stamps it
he goes go go go go go God bless God
bless he was like oh [__] yeah and then
they put me in the room in the hospital
with like the hazmat suits and they
didn't know what it was and I spent like
five days on IV antibiotics with like
four different things running through my
veins and the the doctors were like
Don't Let It Go that close they're like
you went real close on that one yeah
that's what that picture I mean people
should uh check out the book just to see
the picture because I imagine you just
laying there unable to see have a fever
probably so you're like half
hallucinating yep
yeah and uh there's no there's no boat
there's no there's no way out there's no
help coming
um plus there's this creature who you've
become a parent of yeah that you love
yeah
boy that's a dark place to be as a 19
year old I mean most people have never
will never be in a place like that like
where did you find strength in that in
those in that place I don't know I just
remember writing like a goodbye letter
to my parents because I said if I die
out here it was really dark like it was
it was it was terrifying it really felt
like it was the end
and I was writing you know if you find
me out here I'm sorry and all that all
that type of stuff and it was you know
um I don't know about strength there's
no strength it was just like move
forward and at some point it was like if
you'll take me down river take me down
river you know and
you just got lucky with the loggers with
the death boat yeah that they found you
um well how did the infection start by
the way I don't know
I really don't know I mean we always
have some sort of little [__] but the
thing is now JJ taught me that there's
like three different trees that can cure
infections I didn't know this at the
time I didn't know the cheat codes now
there's there's if you have a small
infection you can use Sangre de Drago
and it'll it'll cure it right away like
let's say you have a botfly and it gets
a little [__] there's a fly living in
your skin you put that on there not only
will it kill the fly but it'll heal the
infection now if you have a worse
infection you can go to oh hey which is
Ficus insipida and you can use that and
that will completely heal that will
murder it's like crocodile blood it will
murder infections so like forget
Neosporin that's a joke these are heavy
chemical compounds running through these
trees and they know all about them and
so
whatever it is so now at this point
that's no longer an issue like because
we know how to handle it which at that
time if JJ had been there I would have
been fine well learn the hard way so
these are open wounds and then there's
creatures that start living in them is
basically what what is it well that's
separate that's bot flies yeah there's
there's a there's a creature that
unfortunately very very very
unfortunately
um likes to make its home inside the
Flesh of mammals yeah and so the Flies
attach their eggs to mosquitoes the
mosquitoes go and seek out warm-blooded
animals the eggs microscopic eggs fall
into your skin and then begin to grow
and sooner or later you feel a twitch
and it's a worm living inside of you
that's like vertical down in you and
it's it's eating you yeah and at first
it's not a problem but when they get to
about as thick as that pen
it starts to hurt because you got a hole
in you and they have a little breathing
tube that comes up and they breathe and
they go back in and then they eat and
they come back up to breathe and you
have a you have a friend living in you
yeah
um and if you've had one of those I've
had lots of those it's tough to take
them out
they have hooks
you gotta love the junkies so how do you
take it out to come yeah 100 uh you
gotta you gotta put an irritant so like
a lot of times what we'll do down there
is some someone will
take a massive drag of a cigarette and
then they'll spit the they'll they'll
powers like exhale and get some of the
some of the tar which also shows you how
much tar you get out of a cigarette and
then with a knife you put that right
over the hole and then uh you slap some
Vaseline or something on top of it so
they can't breathe and eventually over
the course of a few hours they'll come
up enough looking for air and then you
got to grab them with a tweezer and try
not to rip them because then you're
gonna get an infection and you gotta
squeeze from the it's a whole ceremony
when people have bot flies we're all
like oh it's bot fly time let's go and
then like JJ will squeeze he's got like
pliers for thumbs yeah he can like take
a piece of your neck and you think he's
going to break your skin he'll just
squeeze until this thing comes out
and you don't uh yeah I guess there's an
open wound right there and yeah you
don't want to bathe for a day or two
after until that closes because
otherwise you're gonna have like water
slashing around in like a little pocket
of yours is kind of gross and that water
might have other organisms that water in
your skin tends to yeah I mean the
jungle water's clean we drink it like I
drink the water fresh out of the stream
oh that's interesting well it's just a
giant filtration system all those roots
the whole jungle is constantly purifying
everything people might be thinking
about that with the jungle there's
insects probably all over you all the
time
it's not as bad as you think like I've
been to to to to Finland Lapland in the
summer and the mosquitoes are horrendous
like devastating the Amazon in in our
area if you're sitting in a hammock
reading a book
out you know our research Stations don't
have walls or anything
um you're good for about one one
mosquito every half hour which really is
not a lot I mean it's worse in New
Jersey like
it's really not that bad tell me a
little more about the the little baby
anteater Lulu they they give who you've
rescued and had to sadly leave behind
yeah I just was always fascinated with
giant anteaters or this you know German
Shepherd sized
thing with Wolverine claws and these
giant Popeye forearms and they excavate
ant and Termite mounds and they have
this long tongue
and their babies right on their back for
the first six months of their lives and
so they actually have this incredibly
intimate relationship with their young
and it just so happens that this animal
that I was wildly fascinated with
there was an orphan on the river and JJ
was like you love these things and I was
like yeah and so he went and he was like
hey my friend you should he got he got
me the the baby and we were like we're
gonna rewild her and so I spent like
weeks and weeks and weeks just like with
this thing on my back crawling through
the jungle teaching her to find Ants
giving her milk falling asleep with her
on my chest and their their tongue is
like 11 inches long at that age and so
she when she wanted me to wake up she'd
fired up my nose and would come out my
mouth and she'd and then if I tried to
get her off me quick she'd stick the
claws in and you know on all my clothes
I have like I have old like you know now
they're like you know like Museum pieces
with rips in them from from Lulu's claws
was able to also communicate emotion and
feeling and all that she needed it she
needed it so if this animal didn't have
the physical touch if we didn't if I
didn't hold her all day long
she'd throw Tantrums she'd go shred
something she'd go pull down the curtain
she'd go ruin the woods just should
start literally having a traumatic
response to not having intimacy
which was shocking because again on the
scale of a cockroach to an elephant you
go
I didn't know that giant and theaters
had such intense emotions like
but she did and we we you know and also
taking care of her forced me
to to explore the jungle from the
perspective of an animal
so I got to like be an animal
and so there's only a few times in your
life in my life where I've gotten to do
that you know one was with her another
time was living with a herd of elephants
where I had to walk with them through
the forest and like see how they
interacted
completely natural and it's it's it's
different it's very different and you
realize like just like a person's public
Persona when they're out on the street
in Manhattan is going to be very
different than when you're on the couch
with them on a Tuesday night
and and and with wild animals it's very
much like that you know like if we see
you see a bobcat on a trail and it's
going to look at you and glare at you
and then go off and it's like yeah but
what's it like when it's in the den
that's playing with its Cubs yeah so
that when it's looking at you that's
like the Instagram post it's making and
the actual face yeah